This is the Chris Abraham Show.
Hey, good morning.
It's Chris Abraham, The Chris
Abraham Show in season five,
episode 45.
So I'm just going to noodle on
about Donald Trump for the
entire time it takes me to walk
to Adidas Coffee.
And because I'm feeling a lot of
wind on me, I'm going to run
this through that Adobe AI audio
cleaning tool because I don't
like the sound of the I.
And then I'll run it through
Normalize and compression.
We'll see what happens.
But if you hear any weird, like
Chris Abraham speaking in
tongues, that's the result of
the AI.
Mishearing things and
mistranslating things.
So please excuse me.
So I have a target on my back,
which is to say, everybody
thinks that I'm a Trumpy, but
I'm not a Trumpy.
I love Trump because of what it
brings out in people.
America hasn't really had a
populist president in 50 years,
right?
And.
We really haven't had an
isolationist, nationalist,
populist president in in in I
don't know, I wasn't alive.
So while all of my friends have
been losing, literally losing
their shit and while the entire
federal government.
The lifers, Lifer Govey's, the
all of my fancy friends from the
fancy group I used to go to.
All the smartest people I know.
All the sanest people I know all
the wise people.
I know all the mellow people.
I know all the circumspect
people.
I know all the Yogini's and
Yogi's.
I know all the transcendent
people of great wisdom.
All the people I thought were
the Solomons in my life while
they've been looking at Trump
and having little literal Trump
Derangement Syndrome, I want
everybody to know that the world
and me and all the populists in
the country haven't been looking
at Trump.
They've been looking at you
looking at Trump.
They've been watching.
Really.
Like extreme behaviors that seem
completely antithetical to
everything that is spoken when
one speaks.
As Solomon speaks, Right.
Like all the talk about First
Amendment rights?
Freedom of speech.
Due process.
The priesthood.
The hallowed priesthood known as
journalism and reporting, The
hallowed history of The New York
Times and the Washington Post.
All of the respect associated
being both a.
Being both a what you McCall a
senator as well as a
representative, all the concepts
of fairness and gentility and
one is innocent until proven
guilty.
And the hallowed nature of the
Supreme Court, which has always
been considered to be almost our
own, Solomons, all of these
things.
Have fallen to this concept of
by any means necessary, all
standards, all expectations, all
every single vestige of
integrity, every single vestige
of willingness to be truthful,
transcendent, to ignore
politics, to ignore, ignore
partisanship, every single
person in this country who has
establishment power.
Over the levers, levers and
controls of the United States
have collectively, from the very
moment that Trump was elected
and shamelessly not even in like
the concept of by any means
necessary to destroy this
populist uprising when it was
the Tea Party, only it was
something that was done.
I don't know, discreetly.
It was done under a certain
guise of paternalism and
maternalism that these were just
miscreants that should be
reintegrated or just have a
little bit of a red flag on them
or whatnot.
It was but.
This time, the country is really
scared.
And when you're afraid, as I
learned when I was a dive
instructor, well, dive master, I
learned that panicked people
tend to take everybody down with
them.
So when I was a Patty dive
master working in Hawaii, in
Hawaii, it was my job to be the
assistant to the dive master,
the dive instructor.
And one of the early things you
learn is a dive dive master is
that when you have to deal with
a client who is panicking or who
whose eyes turn as big as pies
and you know is about to bolt to
the surface, or when they start
freaking out and you can tell
that they are having a complete
conniption.
It is really dangerous to
approach them face to face.
You have to move up behind them.
You need to control them from
their their bottle of air from
their tank, because they will
reach out and they will grab
your mask, they will grab your
second stage, they'll grab your
regulator, they'll they'll mess
you up.
And that's the kind of panic the
country's going through.
Because I believe that in a
world where the populace the the
general population, the Gen.
Pop I'll call them from now on,
instead of calling them the
moral majority or the whatever
silent majority, I'll call them
Gen.
Pop up until now.
The elephant hasn't realized
that it's tethered by a sapling
because when it was a baby
elephant, it was tethered to the
sapling and the sapling was able
to to to control it, to keep it
there.
And then when it grew up to be a
full size pack of derm, it
assumed that the sapling was
still able to to keep it rooted.
When we live in IT, we live in a
government where 20%, if not 3%
of the people, super educated,
super rich, super powerful,
super connected, super shameless
people have control over, you
know, 97% of the population.
When my buddy Agent Kay told me
Homeland Security.
Domestic security, policing,
FBI, Secret Service, local cops,
and so forth, right?
There is no ability to control
the population unless the
population controls itself,
because if the population became
uncontrollable, there really are
not enough boots on the ground.
To return the community to
civility, the exact nature of
cops and cop cars, and of a
threat of going to jail and a a
threat of prison, is to make you
mind your own manners.
But if your manners are not
minded, and if you don't mind
your manners yourself, there is
0.
One can do to reclaim that
control.
Once the elephant knows that it
can overpower the sapling with
no problem.
Once the elephant knows that
that it's an elephant and that
everybody around it is sort of a
mouse, then things get really
scary.
Like I I reached out to Bard and
to ChatGPT yesterday.
And asked them if if a
government knows that it's
losing control of the
population, what are extreme
examples of behaviors that that
government is want to do?
And it's like, it's like, come
on guys, with regards to Trump,
we all know that the moment he
was elected, there was a he's
not my president campaign, There
was a.
Extreme white blood level white
blood cell response.
To him, there was an extreme
cancerous response.
His his Department of Justice.
They were decidedly not on his
side even though they professed
loyalty to him.
All the fealty was a lie.
All the loyalty was a lie.
All the Trump love was a lie.
The establishment on both sides,
the neolibs and neocon Tom
Neocons by definition were
having a complete conniption fit
and being obstructionist every
chance they could.
Which is to say that none of the
legal pushes to get the election
which.
All the populace in this country
still believe the election was
stolen.
I know that all the neolibs
believe that the election was
stolen in favor of Trump, but we
know that nobody wanted him to
be elected.
So the fear is, is that he'll
easily be elected this time.
And whether or not I believe
that the election was stolen to
make sure that Trump was not
elected, I think that.
Everybody watched everything
happen in real time.
Everybody was on their own
version of of IRC, everybody was
on their own version of Discord
server, and everybody was on
their version of Twitter and
Mastodon.
And they were seeing the numbers
happened and they were seeing
that at 3:00 AM the night of
lots of things changed and.
People perceive it as no matter
what happens in the next
election, Trump will have 90
million votes, and no matter
what, Biden will have 91 million
votes.
So no matter what happens,
there's a perception by American
populists who are watching, I
mean.
There is such a strong belief
that it's, you know, not unlike
the kind of belief that people
have you know about 911 or what
not like.
They see.
They see January 6 turn from a
molehill to a mountain.
They see things like Russia,
Gate and.
Christopher Steele and the
Steele dossier, they see all
these things collapsing.
They see the dispute that the
Hunter laptop was Russian
propaganda or or or a fate or
whatnot.
They see that the very like
within weeks those things are
disputed and they are debunked
as false.
But it doesn't matter, right?
Kyle Rittenhouse didn't kill any
black people.
He only killed white people.
But if you talk to anybody, Kyle
Rittenhouse killed black people.
Indeed, This is one example.
So as I watched this happen, I'm
never watching Trump.
Trump is.
He's just a placeholder, right?
Like he is an example.
He's a represent representative
of all these populists these he
is them and they are not
Christian.
They are not against abortion.
They're they're not neo cons.
They're not GOP.
They're not Grand Old Party, if
anything.
Trump and his Trumpers are the
rhinos Republican by name only
or whatever.
Trump is not a Republican.
Republicans are socially
conservative, fiscally
conservative, small government.
Traditionally speaking.
If we transition that to modern
establishment Republicans, they
tend to be.
Globalists.
They tend to be adventurous.
They tend to invade people.
They tend to create environments
where they get to use the moral
high ground to to invade
countries that haven't asked our
permission.
Right, for example.
Hate to say it, but Syria?
And Assad invited Putin and
Russia to help protect Syria
against the rebels and
eventually the Americans.
In many cases.
We've been funding the Kurds.
We've been funding lots of
groups.
We've been fomenting change.
We've been fomenting.
Revolution.
We've been behind Color
I don't even know if the Neolibs
and the neocons have any control
over the CIA anymore.
I think that maybe the CIA has
control over the Neolibs and
neocons, or they the the enemy
of my enemy is my friend.
But there has been it.
It's been completely obvious.
The elections seemed really
dodgy.
The fact that no courts would
even allow any of the That was
the first time I realized I was
assumed that you had your day in
court.
I always assumed that you had
your day in court.
But if you but a judge can
decide not to take your case so
you don't have to win or lose a
case, it's as simple as you
know.
Not having the case go to court
at all.
So there's that.
And that's plausible
deniability, right?
If you don't have standing and
if people don't perceive your
argument as having merit, even
if that's politically, even if
that's politically motivated, it
doesn't really matter, right?
Because at the end of the day,
there's nobody at all that's
going ahead and saying.
That there is or isn't
corruption in the voting
process, right?
And I don't know what the term
is, but there's this term in
Islam where you get to basically
do anything during a time of war
and that all of your if you come
into a place of Nini to defend
yourself in the livelihood of
your people.
And yourself and your religion
and the word of Mohammed, peace
be upon him.
Then you can you can adopt the
behaviors of your of your enemy.
You can adopt.
You can fit in, You can drink,
You can carouse.
You can swear.
You can give up prayer five
times a day in order to be at
the ready.
For war to defend your way of
life now because in addition the
mainstream and the authority
let's call me authority.
I don't know really man.
My my buddy Mark is like the
epitome of this.
He is couldn't be more
establishment and he has so much
contempt for Gen.
Pop.
Like he really believes that
they're so stupid that you could
do anything right in front of
them and they're powerless to do
anything about it.
However, there's like 4 to one
right Four dumb Gen. pop for
everyone, 20 Percenter who has
power, control, wealth and
authority.
And so nobody's been watching
Trump since 2016.
Everybody, including people from
around the world, are watching
this bad behavior.
They're watching Trump
Derangement Syndrome.
They're watching the fact that
morals and standards are being
completely thrown aside.
That that that holy sites such
as the New York Times and the
Washington Post have been
weaponized including, believe it
or not, including extremely
hallowed insider sites like, you
know, for example, you know, the
The Economist, the FT foreign
affairs, like all these things
have been, have been used like a
Holy Hand grenade in an attempt
to destroy, defuse and
disempower the populist Gen. pop
of America.
And now these are sadly, they're
not antireligion, right?
They're just not religious per
se.
They're not, if you will,
Christian conservatives.
The Gen. pop.
The worst thing, the scariest
thing about the Gen. pop, is
they're not racist either.
You can call them fastest, you
can call them racist.
You can call them this, you can
call them that.
And a lot of them consider when
they say I want to protect and
support democracy, because
democracy is fragile.
And when you take those things
in vain, when you say you are,
when these people are people who
served in the Army, Navy, Air
Force, Marines, Space Corps and
Coast Guard, or they've been
marshals or or they've been
paramedics.
So they've been firemen, or
they've been ambulance drivers,
or they've been Border Patrol
officers, or they've been G men,
or they've been, I don't know,
even even Secret Service.
And they've been all these
people who have jobs with guns,
basically jobs with guns.
And they pledge allegiance not
to the flag.
They pledge allegiance to the
Constitution.
They purport to uphold the
Constitution against enemies
foreign and domestic, right?
So those people are Gen. pop,
even though they probably take
your paychecks and you feel like
you really must rely heavily
upon their discretion.
When you have a job where you
have pledged to uphold the
Constitution against enemies
foreign and domestic and someone
else is just throwing around,
I'm a patriot.
I believe in the Constitution.
I believe in democracy.
And they're doing things like
wanting to ban guns, or they're
doing things like being
antidemocratic, or they're doing
things like turning the hallowed
priesthood of of journalism into
another NGO or another activist
organization.
Or when everything is
weaponized.
Things that used to be
enriching, they seem to be
dangerous now.
And when people are afraid of
what they're going to say.
Or when the happiness of .3% of
the population is considered to
be more important than the
happiness of the, you know,
99.7% of the population.
When there's a when.
Words are weaponized.
When.
There's overt censorship?
When all of a sudden democracy
becomes this overtly and
pathetic delicate thing that at
any moment can be destroyed by
by a misspoken word.
When?
When people are censored.
When.
When rioters, when thousands of
rioters are thrown into jail,
when.
And this is all done in public,
in front of everybody's face.
Like everybody around the world
can see this happen in real
time, right?
Like nobody's missing it just
because you are.
Just because you are dominating
just because you have complete
political air superiority just
because you are America and Gen.
Pop is basically the Mujahideen
or the Taliban or the poor world
people in the desert.
Just because you have Tier 1,
Tier 2, Tier 3 operators, just
because you have F18 Super
Hornets and F Sixteens and F30
Fives and F20 Twos, just because
you have stealth bombers and
nuclear weapons and and the
Rangers and the Marines and and
Force Recon, Just because you
have those things doesn't mean
that the world can't watch you
decimate villages without any
compassion, without any care
that these are your people.
In many cases this is being
perceived as a a hot cold civil
war.
This is perceived as a type of
of of of maybe not ethnic, but
if you want to call it anti
white then you could say it's a
type of ethnic cleansing.
I wouldn't.
I believe that it's openly and
awkwardly A cultural revolution.
I believe that it's open and
awkwardly perceived as a purity
test.
A loyalty test.
Will you follow along with the
nomenclature that we just make
up and impose on you gladly?
Will you embrace pronouns?
Will you, when asked, will you
not know the definition of what
is a woman?
Will you?
I don't know.
Will you gladly consume movies
and television and media and
songs and so forth on the
approved list, whether or not
you would want to spend your
money on it, right?
Like there's a lot of testing.
Will you receive the mRNA
vaccine?
Will you be vaccinated?
Will you wear a mask?
Will you stay at home?
What won't you do?
Do you own a gun?
Do you carry a gun?
Do you possess A highcapacity
semiautomatic gun with a box
magazine?
Do you own a semiautomatic
rifle?
Do you own an AR15 style rifle?
Do you own in Kalashnikov style
rifle?
Do you own a service pistol?
Are you a concealed carry
holder?
How many guns do you have?
How much ammo do you have?
What kind of calibers do you
have?
Do you have a 10 millimeter gun?
That's a bear gun.
That's not fair.
Do you do you run hollow points?
Do you?
I don't know.
Anyway, I'm almost here at
Idito's and I think that that's
enough.
But like I said, it's not even
about Trump.
It's not even about the Trump
Replicants.
Trump is sort of a Unicorn,
right?
He is the he is the heel in
America's WWE wrestling match
and he's be overwhelmed by all
these spaces and it's a stress
test in many ways.
The the pop, the Gen. pop and
had an opportunity to see how
people behave in environments
where they're extremely unhappy
with with outcome and behavior
and the progress of Saints.
Anyway, I hope you're well and
I'll talk to you soon.
Mahalo.
Love you.
Bye, bye.
Thank you for listening to The
Chris Abraham Show.
Make sure you subscribe so you
don't miss any future episodes.
Until next time,
oh, thank you.